the most popular game from barstool
sports now available in the palm of your
hand
questions as [ __ ] up as you are in
your pocket download answer the internet
hi this is rosebud baker and this is
answer the internet
would you kill baby hitler if it had to
be in a very gruesome way
i mean um is there an is there a nice
way to kill a baby i don't
i guess suffocating it
abortion would i abort baby no okay
um yeah i guess so i guess
if i was if there was some proof that it
was gonna be hitler
uh if honestly if you just showed me his
mustache and that was it i'd be like
let's get rid of this baby
would you date your dream guy if for two
days
every week your choice he had to dress
like a juggalo
yeah i guess no but mostly
not because of the dressing like a
juggalo it's just the
having to dress like it what deal did
you make
with and with who that you have to
he's if if you're like why do you have
to and he's like i can't talk about it
that i'm
like all right well we're done i i'm
your past is scary
you rather have teeth where your hair is
or hair where your teeth are
um i would say teeth where my hair is
because i can because that way
i can be like uh sarah from the land of
time land before time
and just if if you have teeth on your
head you can headbutt anybody
and um think about brushing yeah
maintain them get the toothbrush out
it's going to feel good that's got to
feel great you give yourself a head
massage every night while you're
brushing your teeth
[ __ ] yeah i don't know there's something
there's like an asmr thing to it
i kind of like it this actually isn't
that odd of a question
i'm into it and um if there's anyone
that can do this
you can hit me up at rosebud baker on
twitter and instagram
um would you rather your boyfriend be
able to read your thoughts during sex or
all the time except during sex
oh [ __ ]
um i think all the time except during
sex
really yeah i think my thoughts during
sex are
probably would probably hurt his
feelings more
i'm sorry andy i love you please don't
call off the wedding
i can defend my thoughts during the day
i don't know if i can defend my thoughts
during sex you know what i mean like
wish you were an nba team
i can't i can't defend that
if you had to choose one cartoon animal
to have sex with
who would it be cartoon animal
um oh god i i'm
well just said i would [ __ ]
uh archer but because
i think he's an animal in bed
does that work what's the youngest aged
child that could beat you up the
youngest aged child
that could beat me up honestly i'll [ __ ]
a kid up
they can't no kid's gonna you can answer
the other way too yeah
um what's the youngest age child i would
beat up
is uh is the question and i would say um
eight-year-olds eight they just turn
shitty
i don't know what it is i was a nanny
for years i'm telling you
one to seven angels eight years old [ __ ]
those kids
most never come back let's let's be
honest most of them never return to
what you got to do is you don't have to
kill baby hitler you got to just wait
till he's eight
yeah if i win yeah if hitler turned
eight
and he starts bitching about how i'm
dressed
pick him up from school i'm gonna kick
him in the head sucks too because he'd
probably be attracted to me
uh yeah yeah what would you pick to be
the title of your autobiography
uh whiskey fists would you rather go to
heaven or become a ghost on earth after
you die
oh i um for sure would what's the
difference
honestly i think being a ghost on earth
and getting to [ __ ] with people that
don't know you're there but think that
you're there
uh that is heaven on earth so i'm
that's who would you hunt um
oh god there's so many people uh there's
so many first of all
every one of my black friends because
just the way they
they'd get i get the funniest reactions
out of them for sure
um like matt richards i'd
haunt the [ __ ] out of matt richards um
i uh don't say sloane [ __ ] i would
haunt her every goddamn day of my life
and just watch her try to kill me with a
fly swatter it'd be awesome
how long would you have to starve to
become a cannibal
oh i was a fat kid so i'm going to give
myself
yeah yeah no for real fat like i would
smell the wrappers
um i think uh
i'm going to give myself two weeks if
i'm you know in the woods
two weeks you think i'd die in that well
like
you know you could try to find other i
guess when i think of starbucks
and things like that it feels like
that's something you've been working
yeah
yeah i feel like if there's if there's
stuff other options
bugs and [ __ ] i give myself two weeks if
there's nothing
except the person next to me
i'm going to cut that by a week
and i'm not going to apologize what is
a little thing someone can do that
automatically makes them a crazy person
oh [ __ ] there's so many answers to this
oh i know what it is you hit somebody up
because they haven't answered you
and you ask them if they're mad at you
those people
are [ __ ] crazy i those people
need help so wait i text i text you you
don't answer me and then i'm like
are you mad at me yeah if that yeah if
somebody texts me
and then i don't answer one time and the
next text is
did i do something to piss you off i'm
like well now you
now now you're [ __ ] crazy and we're
never talking again
500 years from now and you're the person
in charge of naming this era what would
you call it
oh this question had a new meaning now
yes
this is a question before a pandemic
um the after world